[Music]
windows up grab you like you stole it
[Music]
off isn't work what happened
I gotta do it in my car and the whole
world is watching our nation's first
police officer I can't [ __ ] up my
pension
hey don't get me stabbed why bullets
always gotta be the bad guys so that
night we responded to a 415 disturbance
car immediately took fire [ __ ] can you
make a shootout awkward that grants
wishes and it just went really sideways
from that point on Lisa magics try and
kill
[Music]
we have to protect the wand so I need to
know if that you got my back you cop
first or pork first starting to analyze
[ __ ] you I want it done let's do it
we're gonna titty bar gunfight dive
dreams are the nightmare
feels like a dog on the pieces Tommy
a lot of fingers we were doing so good
[Music]
are we friends I think we should spend
our time just trying to survive this
year
[Music]
we'll be heroes forever
I need you to take your fat Shrek
looking ass beggar [ __ ] home to Fiona
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]